vi siete mai chiesti cosa sia il piacere
io ero solo una bambina quando per la
prima volta entrato sul traghetto chiese
ai miei genitori come facevo a capire se
il mare mi piaceva o meno non ricordo
minimamente cosa mi risposero ma quella
domanda mi ha accompagnato per molti
anni anche durante i miei studi di
psicologia come faccio a capire se
quell'università mi piace come capisco
realmente se quel lavoro fa per me
sono domande che ognuno di noi si fa
quotidianamente siamo abituati a
ragionare deflettere in termini di
piacere o non piacere
mangio questo perché mi piace oppure
vado in palestra anche se non vi piace
affatto
ma quando ho iniziato a interessarmi ai
meccanismi emotivi dell'erotismo umano
al punto da fondare con alcuni colleghi
la società italiana di sessuologia e
psicologia
mi sono resa conto di quanto quando
parliamo di sessualità questa certezza
sul piacere diventa più confusa
se io vi chiedessi ora qui come stata la
vostra ultima esperienza sessuale
se è stata soddisfacente per voi
probabilmente molti di voi per
rispondermi andrebbero a rispolverare il
momento dell'orgasmo
l'ho provato oppure no è stato intenso
oppure no lo simulato
non vi preoccupate non vi chiederò di
fare un sondaggio su questo perché vedo
numerose coppie in sala quindi evitiamo
questo momento ma è incredibile
sorprendente quanto tendiamo a
ricondurre il piacere sessuale un unico
momento a una singola sensazione ma se
io vi dicessi che in realtà il piacere
sessuale qualcosa di più ampio è quello
che ci fa dire molto semplicemente ho
voglia o non ho voglia di di rivederti
il piacere sessuale è gioco e benessere
divertimento ma soprattutto e libertà sì
perché per provare piacere sessuale
bisogna sentirsi liberi di giocare e
sperimentare ora può sembrare banale
questa affermazione
noi tutti siamo cresciuti con questo
concetto di libertà io stessa quando ero
adolescente ero libera di sperimentare
ero libera di avere una mia attività
sessuale ero libera di andare dalla
ginecologa se voleva o per lo meno così
pensavo comunque noi siamo nati con
un'idea di libertà sessuale ma questa
idea è nuova io come molti di voi in
sala sono una figlia della rivoluzione
sessuale degli anni 60 e 70
io non l'ho vissuta in prima persona ma
i miei genitori di sì e di storie me ne
hanno raccontate parecchie ma è grazie a
quel periodo che io oggi posso stare qui
di fronte a voi a parlare di sessualità
di orgasmo di piacere senza rischiare di
arrossire o peggio di essere arrestata
e grazie a quel periodo che io nel mio
lavoro posso parlare di salute sessuale
di erotismo di masturbazione
ma se la generazione precedente ha
vissuto gli anni della liberalizzazione
sessuale
noi oggi stiamo vivendo
gli anni della globalizzazione della
sessualità gli anni in cui piacere
sessuale è diventato un vero e proprio
prodotto di mercato
un fenomeno sociale in continuo sviluppo
espansione un po per curiosità un po
ovviamente per il lavoro che faccio
tendo a informarmi a rimanere sempre
informati sulle ultime novità in questo
settore ma anche quando qualcosa mi
sfugge qualche notizia dell'ultima ora
non mi arriva
ecco che i ragazzi delle scuole oi miei
pazienti sono pronti li a ricordarmi con
che velocità questo settore si muove
ricordo ancora una volta in un corso in
una scuola romana che un ragazzo poco
più che adolescente mi chiese cosa ne
pensassi del petting qualcuno di voi sa
di cosa sto parlando
perfetto neanche io lo sapevo
eppure ero io l'esperta del settore in
quel momento quindi con estrema
semplicità gli ho chiesto che cosa
intendesse la mi ha risposto quando la
donna fa sesso anale all'uomo che non lo
sa no non ne avevo la più pallida idea
ma non della pratica del termine ogni
giorno nascono termini nuovi che vanno a
definire delle pratiche più antiche di
chi quell'espressione la cognata massimo
le conosci sei out sia che tu sia un
adolescente sia che tu sia un esperto
del settore
i ragazzi di oggi possono viaggiare in
giro per il mondo e fare la fila non
agli uffizi ma al museo del sesso
possono leggere di sessualità ovunque
sul blog su internet su interviste su
articoli di giornale possono scaricare
app a contenuto sessuale possono
iscriversi a chat di incontri o comprare
dei widget da attaccare al di smartphone
per il sesso a distanza in quanto a
piacere esplorazio
a me non siamo secondi a nessuno i sex
toys ormai un must da tenere in borsetta
oppure la tanto discussa pornografia in
poco meno di vent'anni dall'uscita
online del primo sito hard oggi si
contano oltre 420 milioni di pagine a
contenuto pornografico
praticamente il business economico più
grande di sempre dopo il petrolio ma
parliamo di salute sessuale
oggi esistono centinaia e centinaia di
tipologie di condom classificabili in
base al gusto alla misura alla
vestibilità al colore o all'effetto sul
funzionamento sessuale
se in sala c'è qualche vegano o qualche
amante del bacon state tranquilli c'è un
condom anche per voi sono usciti la
settimana scorsa quindi migliaia di
tipologie per tutti i gusti e tutte le
fantasie la pillola anticoncezionale
stesso felice e sviluppo in poco meno di
40 anni dalla sua uscita sul mercato
oggi esistono decine di tipologie in
base al dosaggio ormonale alle esigenze
della donna o più banalmente base al
costo quindi da quello che abbiamo
appena visto
possiamo dire tranquillamente che la
libertà di accedere al piacere sessuale
è stata sdoganata vi ricordate quel
ragazzo che mi chiedeva informazioni sul
the king
beh quello stesso ragazzo dopo pochi
minuti mia ha dichiarato alla classe di
non aver mai usato un preservativo in
vita sua pur avendo una vita
sessualmente attiva
allora come è possibile che la
generazione più preparata di sempre se
anche la stessa che si approccia
contatta difficoltà ai prodotti che oggi
a disposizione
oggi come oggi
le malattie a trasmissione sessuale o le
infezioni sessualmente trasmesse
rappresentano ancora un problema
sanitario evidente le gravidanze
indesiderate o le interruzioni
volontarie di gravidanza sono un
problema per le giovanissime del nostro
paese è in continuo aumento
l'utilizzo di farmaci per sostenere
l'eccitazione il desiderio almeno quanto
il ricorso a sostanze come la droga o
l'alcol per sostenere un incontro
sessuale fenomeni di sexting lanza per
l'incontro con l'altro
l'isolamento sociale la preoccupazione
per le misure del proprio corpo sono
ormai delle problematiche reali con cui
esperti con cui noi esperti del settore
ci troviamo a dover affrontare
quotidianamente
quindi cosa è successo dalla libertà di
provare piacere sessuale all'angoscia
legata alla nostra sessualità
capita sempre più spesso di sentire
ragazzi affermare frasi tipo se una
ragazza propone il preservativo durante
un rapporto sessuale vuol dire che non
si fida del proprio compagno
oppure masturbazione pornografia sono
cose da maschi non da femmina oppure il
must dei must perché si sa le dimensioni
contano oggi la libertà sessuale si è
trasformata in un dovere
oggi dobbiamo fare sesso il prima
possibile e va fatto pure per bene
oggi il desiderio sessuale deve essere
sempre al di sopra delle nostre capacità
non importa che ci hanno recitato al
lavoro che domani abbiamo un esame
all'università che abbiamo litigato in
famiglia o che mio figlio mi ha rotto il
portatile con una pallonata non importa
devo essere sempre pronta scattante i
concetti di performance e di successo
ormai hanno instaurato un rapporto
piuttosto angoscioso con la sessualità
ma se ci pensiamo non solo con su questa
performanti e perfetti dobbiamo esserlo
sempre ovunque in ogni rapporto
la nostra vita in famiglia lavoro ma
perfetti come chi ognuno di noi da
inseguire un modello nell'ambito della
sessualità ma non ha idea di che modello
sia sempre più spesso i ragazzi delle
scuole fanno domande tipo quando è
normale fare sesso la prima volta oppure
quali sono le dimensioni giuste di un
rapporto sessuale o ancora quante volte
devo fare sesso in un mese con il mio
ragazzo la mia ragazza perché la mia
coppia sia considerata sana tutte
domande che i ragazzi si fanno alla
ricerca di risposte che in qualche modo
possano rassicurarli domande che molto
spesso non trovano risposte a noi adulti
e quindi ragazzi tendono a cercare le
loro risposte per altri canali
pensiamo al gruppo dei pari pensiamo a
internet pensiamo alla pornografia
canali che nascono per generare risposte
ma non per fornire domande è come se
oggi se si mosse stando a una corsa a
due velocità da una parte abbiamo lo
sviluppo tecnologico che è veloce chiaro
fantasioso segue le logiche del mercato
dall'altro abbiamo lo sviluppo
individuale che è più lento perché a che
fare con l'individuo e richiede
necessariamente un tempo diverso per
evolversi dalla libertà del piacere
sessuale al dovere della nostra
sessualità
in tutto questo discorso abbiamo
semplicemente rovesciato la nostra
prospettiva il nostro rapporto con la
sessualità è rimasto identico normativo
cosa devo fare e cosa no cosa sono e
cosa no cosa deve piacermi e cosa no
cosa mi serve per essere uomo e donna e
cosa no
in quest'ottica in questo gap tra
libertà e dovere i copioni sessuali le
norme i pregiudizi
rappresentano in qualche modo quasi una
salvezza per l'individuo un contenitore
a cui aggrapparsi per provare a
decifrare le centinaia di informazioni
che lo raggiungono e che gli dicono chi
dovrebbe essere cosa dovrebbe provare e
quanto dovrebbe piacergli la nuova sfida
è proprio questa quella di liberare la
sessualità da questi doveri liberare la
sessualità da questi pregiudizi
una ragazza di una scuola media una
volta bene a scuola e ci raccontò il
classico discorsetto che le fece la
madre dopo che ha avuto le sue prime
mestruazioni
la conversazione andata grosso modo così
mamma penso mi sia venuto il ciclo
auguri è diventata una donnina attenta
che adesso rimane incinta e ti rovini la
vita tua mia e di tuo padre
adesso andiamo a festeggiare
ok festeggiare cosa tendiamo a
trasmettere un rapporto legato all'ansia
ai rischi ai pericoli della sessualità
ma così facendo non facciamo altro che
aumentare il livello di paura
le nostre ragazze si sale s.romano di
fronte alla paura
tendo a fare un'unica cosa scappare
per questo motivo è importante iniziare
a parlare ai ragazzi della loro identità
iniziare a parlare a loro di quello che
gli piace cominciare a presentare la
sessualità in termini di piacere e non
di dovere solo così genereremo il loro
la possibilità di scegliere
consapevolmente in salute come muoversi
ma per farlo bisogna anche imparare a
dialogare con le nuove tecnologie
conoscerne le caratteristiche e punti di
forza non si può oggi andare da un
ragazzo e dirgli che internet è la fonte
dei suoi problemi non si può intanto
perché la prima cosa che farebbe
quella di allontanarci a ignorarci e
secondo poi semplicemente perché non è
vero
le nuove tecnologie come internet ad
esempio vengono utilizzati dai ragazzi
come strumento per trovare risposta alle
loro domande
ma solo perché c'è un'assenza di
contenitori in grado di rispondergli
quando possiamo intercettare queste
domande il prima possibile
se ricordate io ero solo una bambina
quando ho cominciato a chiedere a
chiedermi se la libertà vi piace provare
piacere fosse legata a me oa una regola
scritta all'esterno
oggi quello che dobbiamo fare è
intercettare le loro domande ma andare
oltre la richiesta del cosa devo non
devo fare perché dietro a quella domanda
di solito ce n'è sempre un'altra c'è un
bisogno di rassicurazione su loro che
sono c'è bisogno di essere rassicurati
su chi loro si sentono di essere
realmente ormai viviamo in un rapporto
totalmente immaturo con la sessualità
da una parte abbiamo l'estrema libertà
sociale intendo dall'altra c'è lo
sviluppo dell'individuo che è più lenta
e che richiede un tempo diverso quello
che dobbiamo fare come adulti non solo
come esperti come genitori come siccome
insegnanti è quello di rovesciare la
prospettiva per i nostri ragazzi
passare da ciò che è giusto fare a ciò
che è giusto essere da ciò che dovrei
provare a ciò che realmente mi piace
dalla libertà del piacere sessuale al
piacere di sentirsi sessualmente liberi
grazie
[Applauso]